j'échoue leur allons nous séparer je
vais faire une petite interview oui
l'interview dit papa
[Musique]
dit papa tu regrettes saint domingue oui
dibaba thème les 10 de marie laforêt
moyennement mais c'est pas nouveau je
veux dire j'aimais beaucoup marie
laforêt quand c'était une jeune et
superbe actrice mais n'a rien vu une
femme demain je viens bien
dit papa tu crois que je devrais changer
de nom
non
dis papa pourquoi pasqua il bien pu à la
maison
beaudry car je ne répondront pas à ce
type de questions dit papa tu crois que
chirac je peux toujours l'appeler tonton
il ne connaît pas et une photo il avait
l'air de mieux connaître votre compagne
que vous c'est vrai il ya quelques
photos dis papa pourquoi la france l epu
championne du monde de foot quand on
pense ce mouvement a gagné de l'argent
ça ça change un peu la nature des
résultats sportifs comme la politique
oui peut-être que oui c'est vrai dis
papa pourquoi zidane il perd tous ses
cheveux s'il est si fort mais moi aussi
j'ai perdu mes cheveux grâce à toi mon
fils
je sais comment ça rentrait
du papa pourquoi des fois maman elle
crie quand vous dormez
je pense qu'elle doit faire un cauchemar
parce qu'elle dort à côté de moi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu